MARK DYBUL: So I did
want to be really brief,
and I'm going to be even
less coherent than usual
because I was in India yesterday
and I'm a little out of it.
But it's a great opportunity
to talk with you a little bit
about-- less about the
Global Fund, per se,
and more about
amazing opportunity we
have in the world today
around HIV, TB, and malaria,
and more importantly what that
means for us as human beings.
A little bit about
innovation, and then
just have a
conversation, I hope--
and hopefully you're all
more awake than I am.
So AIDS, TB, and malaria.
So these are pretty amazing
diseases in some ways.
For those of you who don't know,
and probably most of you do,
TB and malaria have been around
since recorded medical history,
literally thousands of years.
You can go back as
far as you want,
and you'll find evidence
of malaria or tuberculosis.
And they've been hugely
impactful in human history.
And HIV is kind of the
modern-- not kind of-- it
is the modern-day plague.
It's the disease that's really
had a massive social impact
in the world, really since 1980.
Now a lot of you
may have been born
and don't even remember
a world without HIV.
But some of us do,
and it's really
a radically different place.
I happened to be
in San Francisco
during the worst time
when-- for those of you who
go to San Francisco now
to go to your mothership,
it's hard to describe how
different a place it was.
I mean, it was actually
a depressing city
where you didn't even want
to be because everyone
was dying all the time, and
life revolved around funerals.
It was actually a
terrible place to be.
But because of
advances in science,
because of massive investments
started really by the United
States under President Bush,
but then taken up globally,
because of the
leadership we're seeing
in the countries themselves,
we actually are on the verge of
and have the capability
to do something
that seemed impossible 15 years
ago, which is actually end them
as epidemics-- remove
malaria and tuberculosis
from the planet, which
again, that's been around
for thousands of years.
And while we can't eliminate
in the same way HIV,
yet, we can bring it
down to such low levels
that people wouldn't even
have to talk about it anymore,
what we call
epidemiological control.
There's a really fancy term
for it I won't tell you about,
but low level endemicity.
And then when we get a
partially effective vaccine,
that would be it.
So that's really cool, right?
I mean, these are things
we actually can end.
It takes a lot of work,
takes a lot of effort,
and takes a lot of focus,
but we can actually do it.
And this is the first generation
that's had that capacity.
This is the first
generation in thousands
of years that's had the
ability to end tuberculosis
and malaria.
And this is the first time we've
had the ability to end the HIV.
When everything started about
15 years ago around HIV,
it really was
stopping the death.
It was just trying to stop
the hemorrhage and the death
and the depression
that was around cities
like San Francisco and
certainly in Africa.
It was ending the hopelessness.
It's impossible to describe
how hopeless people felt.
If you went to a village
in Africa, literally no one
talked about
education, or health,
or bringing up their kids.
They all thought they
were going to die.
And it was a pretty
good bet, actually,
just 15 years ago--
just 15 years ago.
15 years later, we can actually
see the end of these epidemics.
In some ways, even more
exciting than that,
is what that would mean for us
as a human race and as people.
So you know most infections
are pretty indiscriminate,
whether it's the absolute
hysteria about Zika, which
is totally unfounded
in anything scientific
or Ebola or influenza, if you
come into contact with it--
in fact, all of you probably
over the last couple of months
get sick fairly
regularly because you
come to work and
touch door knobs
and shake each other's hands.
And you get sick.
And it doesn't matter
if you're rich or poor,
or what color you are, or
if you're gay or straight.
If you come into contact
with an infectious disease
or an infectious element,
you have a pretty good chance
of getting infected.
HIV and TB are very
different diseases.
They're actually
diseases of the most
marginalized and
vulnerable in society.
TB is fundamentally
today a disease
of the poor of the poorest
of the poor in inner cities,
living together in close
quarters with no access
to medical care.
Or it's linked to
HIV because for those
of you who don't know, HIV
per se doesn't kill you.
HIV destroys your immune system
so you die from other things.
And actually TB is the
main thing people die from.
So TB and HIV are
very closely related.
And the people who are
most at risk of HIV
are, again, the most vulnerable
marginalized in society.
So it's the LGBTI
community, particularly gay
and transgender.
And the numbers are frightening.
I mean, if you go to
Latin America, Asia where
the epidemic is largely
controlled, 30%, 40% 50%
of trans and MSM
are HIV positive.
It's related to sex work.
Sex workers are
very highly at risk,
people who inject
drugs, prisoners,
and migratory populations.
That's who is at risk
of tuberculosis and HIV.
So unlike most
infectious diseases
that are indiscriminate,
these diseases
are incredibly discriminatory.
In fact, they prey
on discrimination.
And they prey on the most
marginalized and vulnerable
who don't have
access to services,
who are left behind by society.
And so to end the HIV and
tuberculosis epidemics,
we actually have to become
better people, which
is not actually the case with
most infectious diseases.
We have to create an
inclusive human family
where everyone is welcomed,
where everyone has access
to health, where discrimination
and stigma no longer prevent
people from accessing
their basic human rights
and access to health care.
And that's pretty extraordinary.
I mean, when you can end these
epidemics that have been around
for millennia and
the modern plague,
but the only way
you can do it is
by creating a society we want
to have for the world, that's
really cool.
And that's pretty
rare when you can
pull these two things together.
And I think that's one
of the reasons we're
so excited about the current
opportunity where we are today.
And it's hugely exciting, but
it's also a little frightening
because the world's a pretty
scary place in some ways
right now.
But it's also a world that's
filled with opportunity.
I was just in
India, I mentioned.
I met with a group of
about 40 NGOs, mostly
sex work trans, MSM programs.
They were crowded in a
room about this size.
If we tried to have that
same meeting 15 years ago,
we basically would be meeting
in a closet with two people
and whispering because
no one would have
wanted to know who we were.
And while they were
complaining, and appropriately,
that they don't have the
access that they want,
that there's still
discrimination, just the fact
that they were there
was extraordinary.
You see the same thing in
Nigeria, and Haiti, Kenya,
no matter where I go, in Asia.
When I first went to
China and Vietnam,
the part of the
Department of Health
that dealt with
the gay population,
the transgender population,
the people who inject drugs,
was known as the
Department of Social Evils.
Now it's part of the
Ministry of Health,
and I go to gay, MSM,
and trans programs
with the Minister of Health.
It's really changed.
It's changed tremendously.
And it's changing
in a stepwise kind
of genetic leap way, not
a slow progressive way,
but a genetic leap way.
And I want to talk a little bit
about that genetic leap way,
and one of the groups we
don't talk enough about--
and it's astounding the number
of people who are actually
involved in HIV,
including in Africa,
who don't understand those.
But the key affected population,
or the key population most
at risk for HIV today, is not
the traditional populations.
It's actually young
women, adolescent girls
and young women.
The rates are astronomical.
The rates are five times higher
than in boys, adolescent boys
and young men.
And it's largely driven
by transgenerational sex,
but it's largely
driven by the fact
that women aren't counted
as part of society.
Adolescent girls aren't counted
as an equal part of society.
And so gender-based
violence is rampant.
Abuse is rampant.
Somewhere in the neighborhood
of 40% to 60% of girls
will have their first
sexual encounter
through force or abuse in
parts of southern Africa.
When a girl is born,
she's not even registered.
That's how little
they count in society.
It's total gender
inequality that's
driving the HIV epidemic
in southern Africa.
And so we actually can't
tackle and end the epidemic
unless we get a hold
of gender inequality,
and that's one of the areas
that don't often come up,
particularly in
the United States
where it was largely
a gay-driven epidemic,
still kind of is.
But when you get
outside, it actually
is very much-- and
southern Africa
is where the epidemic
is most out of control
or least in control, and it
is heavily, heavily driven
by gender inequality.
And so we can't end the epidemic
without not only dealing
with the traditional
populations that are left behind
but by a population that's half
the world that we don't even
often think of as a
vulnerable population,
but it's adolescent
girls and young women.
And what's particularly
frightening is
because the birth
rate is so high,
the number of girls,
women and boys,
actually, who are
15 to 24, which
is the most at
risk group for HIV,
because it's the most sexually
active, is going to double.
That means that even if
we reduce the rate of HIV
by 50% in this population, we'll
still have a growing epidemic.
And we never reduce the rate
by 50% in a group like this.
So it's a really frightening
demographic picture,
and it really tells
us how important
dealing with fundamental
structural inequality issues
are for ending an
infectious disease.
Now that youth bulge also
has a huge opportunity
because normally it takes
a generation or generations
to change issues of
human rights and equity.
But when it's a lot of
young people, that's
going to be 60%
of the population,
you can actually
change much faster.
Because if that generation
changes their view,
within 10 years,
they're actually
the majority of the population.
Rather than waiting
for slow change,
waiting for what the Romans
used to call "hope in death,"
waiting for people to die
off so things could change,
it can actually
change radically.
And it can change
radically even where
you don't have that because
of the work you all do,
because of the ability of
people to connect in a way
that we weren't able
to do not long ago.
And so social
movements can lead us
from where we were 10
years ago on gay rights
in this country to where
we are today, like that.
And that's something that's
a pretty remarkable thing
in social dynamics and pretty
remarkable thing lately.
Instead of going to multiple
generations of women fighting
for the right to
vote over 50 years,
you can change
things in five years.
And that's the huge opportunity
today to end these epidemics,
but to do it by becoming the
inclusive human family we want
to be, and by thinking about how
we use mechanisms that we use
to sell things to
talk to each other,
to connect to each other, to
actually change who we are
and change our society.
And that type of innovation,
I'm sorry to say,
global public health
or public health
is not particularly good at.
In fact, we're awful at it.
You'll still see billboards
for anti-HIV campaigns.
I don't know the last time
someone actually looked
at a billboard.
We still do ads in papers
and just nonsense stuff.
No one's actually tapped
into the social-- they still
go to bars to pass out condoms.
People don't meet in
bars anymore for the most
part for sexual encounters.
There are other ways to do it.
And no one's reached
into this world yet.
No one has reached
There are a couple of efforts
to kind of eek our way in.
And then think not only about
how you would do it here,
but how would you
do it in Africa?
How would you reach
young people in Africa?
Well, all of them
have cell phones.
All of them are online.
All of them are
talking to each other.
They're not listening to
their tribal leaders anymore.
They're connecting to the world.
So how do we connect and
create a social movement
that will actually
drive these changes that
are essential for us
to end the epidemics?
But we can't do it without
changing who we are.
And that's really cool.
That's fundamentally different
than, say, Ebola, right?
You didn't need a social
movement to end Ebola.
You just needed to contain it.
To end these
epidemics, we actually
need social movement
and social change
and a radical shift
in human rights.
And that's, I think, one
of the most exciting things
and why a lot of us get so
energized about the potential
because it's not
just an infection.
It's actually an
infection of society.
It's an infection of our values.
And there's a correction
to that infection.
And it's not going
to come from a pill.
So it's great to be
here because you're
all the ones who can help us
figure out how to do all that.
I'd be happy to
talk about anything
you want to talk about, but
thanks for taking your time
and thanks for interest
in these diseases.
Because to be honest,
there's not a lot
of interest in them anymore.
We're losing that
pretty quickly.
And if you guys don't engage, if
your generation doesn't engage,
we will lose the opportunity
to end these epidemics.
And the next generation and the
next generation will still be
dealing with them
because we didn't.
So I hope you join us and
figure out how to do it.
So I'd be happy to
take any questions.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for being here.
It's cool to see you.
Yeah, I just wondered--
MARK DYBUL: Maybe your
name would be helpful, or--
AUDIENCE: Oh yeah.
My name is Christian,
software engineer.
Only by secondary interest,
I'm interested in these things.
So it's amazing
for me too that you
see this as a social problem
and can actually change society.
Do you know, like especially
sub-Saharan Africa,
about some social experiments
that have been conducted,
like that there's some countries
that have really succeeded
in doing this and some
experiments that have not
succeeded very well?
Like basically,
how do we solve it?
MARK DYBUL: We actually don't
have experiments per se.
I mean, it's really hard.
We have a lot of
experiments on drugs.
We know which drugs to use.
We know how to use them.
But then we don't know how to
get people to actually take
them every day, which
is a behavioral thing.
It's part of social
change too, right?
That's why we have these
massive drug resistance
profiles because people
aren't taking them.
But we do have behavioral
studies around adherence
and how to increase adherence.
So that we're getting
pretty good at it.
In terms of how you actually
change sexual behavior,
societal behavior,
we have nothing
in the way of good studies.
And the reason is it's really
hard to control for things.
You can't really do
randomized control trials.
You know, there are no good
randomized controlled trials
on how to stop smoking.
They moved past that.
The only thing that's ever
been proven to reduce smoking
is laws and taxes.
So there are actually no data
because it's really tough
to do the randomized controlled
trial on all the social change
that has happened
over the last 30 years
to basically stigmatize
smoking, all the campaigns.
None of that has
ever been proven
to make any difference
whatsoever because it's
impossible to do that study.
So that comes to the
art of public health,
using common sense, trying to
figure out what works and what
doesn't.
And basically you throw as much
as you can at the wall and see
if it sticks.
So sadly, there are
almost no places
where we've seen reductions
in, say, adolescent girls
and young women.
And it's actually hard to study.
It's really hard
to study the rates.
What we have found
recently-- and this
is pretty exciting
to us because it
links education and health--
is that if you can keep girls
in school, secondary
school, the rates of HIV
can drop dramatically.
Because if you're out of school,
your risk is really high.
And the reason is you engage
in transactional sex for things
like cell phone, money.
Families actually
tell their girls
to go-- functionally they tell
their girls to go have sex
to bring some money home.
And so if we can keep
the girls in school,
what a study in Botswana showed
is for every year a girl stays
in secondary school,
the risk of HIV
drops by 12%, which
is pretty remarkable.
And over time, it
was actually 65%
in a study in Malawi for the
girls who stayed in school.
And the way we were able
to keep them in school
was by giving them a very
small cash incentive,
and either giving
it to the family
so they didn't try
to sell her off
or giving it
directly to the girl
so she didn't have to sell
herself in a transactional way.
And often it's for cell phone
time or it's for school fees
so that they could go to
school or for a uniform
so they could go to school.
So that's one insight.
I'm going to Swaziland
tomorrow, Sunday.
They're actually
launching a program
to do this because
they have a really
high rate in adolescent
girls and young women.
And then we're also doing
gender-based violence programs.
But we don't have
really good studies.
So what we're doing
now is saying,
you know, we're all a
bunch of scientists.
We're never going to have a
randomized controlled trial
that proves this.
What we have to do is just
do a bunch of stuff that
makes sense, that there's links
to, and then study the rates
and see what happens, and don't
worry about whether or not
we can say this or that
specific intervention did it.
Let's just do five
interventions that
seem to make sense and see
if the rates come down.
And that's what we're
starting to do now.
The US government
through PEPFAR,
we're supporting this program.
PEPFAR is something that's been
a great bipartisan program.
It's really one of the things
the United States should
be most proud of, really,
largest international health
initiative in history
for a single disease.
No one was putting any money
in global HIV before this.
Now the US is by far the leader.
They have a program that
we're very linked to.
We work really well in-country.
But it's a great question.
We don't know.
And part of the
reason we don't know
is because we have too many
white male older doctors
and scientists
involved in all this
who keep doing the same thing
over, and over, and over again.
We actually need people who'd
say, well, if you did this,
this would be a way
to reach people.
Or have you thought about that?
Or can you do a game?
How would you link young people?
How would you talk
with the young people
online to get them to
understand their risks
and even learn what
their risks are?
So that's what
we're trying to do,
get people interested in this,
which they really haven't been,
and move the scientists
off to the side.
We're great on the pills.
We're going on the medicine.
We're not so good
on social problems.
And so the bottom line
answer is we don't have
the data we would like to have.
We don't even know how to create
So we'd love to have anyone
engaged who wants to be.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
it sounds like it
would be cool to get
psychologists involved--
MARK DYBUL: Anthropologists.
--in this problem.
Yeah, yeah.
MARK DYBUL: We actually
have, but they're also
a bunch of doctors and older.
So, you know--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MARK DYBUL: There
are more and more,
but really, people are moving
away from these diseases.
Just at the moment, really
we're on the right side
of the tipping point right now.
We could get on the wrong
side really quickly.
Everyone talks about
a tipping point.
Tipping points have two
places you can tip, right?
You can go in the
right direction
or the wrong direction.
We're on the right
side of it now,
but we could easily
go the other way.
And we are losing the people
who used to be energized
and interested.
And literally, here
are these meetings,
except if you're
in India, Africa,
and it's the same people who
were doing it 25 years ago.
So I don't know if
psychologists help.
I'd rather have social
media people, actually.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Stephan.
I'd like to know what your plan
is for malaria, because it's
sort of not necessarily a
very social targeted disease.
MARK DYBUL: It's
a great question.
I mean, obviously you all
know you can eliminate malaria
because you don't have
to worry about it, right?
So you can actually
eliminate this infection.
And one of the
reasons I was in India
is India is actually
getting close.
They don't have malaria up
in the northeastern border,
and they launched their
malaria elimination plan.
Malaria, unlike say
HIV and tuberculosis,
is purely a medical disease.
It's mosquitoes.
It's not a social disease.
But it's social to
the extent that it's
linked to sanitation, and water,
and access to health care.
That's why TB is all over.
And it's in India and China.
HIV is heavily in Africa,
and it's heavily in others.
There's probably some
medical reasons to it
we just don't understand.
But malaria is one
that we can eradicate.
The complexity is sticking with
it long enough to eradicate.
So what we've often
done, and actually we've
done this before.
There was a malaria
elimination effort in the '60s.
It did pretty well,
but we didn't carry it
all the way through.
Unless you really eliminate
and eradicate, it comes back.
And it comes back
really quickly.
When the Minister of
Health of Zanzibar, which
is an island, and I was told
that the president's malaria
initiative was going to
support them to end malaria,
he literally said,
oh, that's great.
We know how to do it.
We've done it three times.
And they actually had.
But mosquitoes keep coming back.
They come on a ship.
They come on a plane.
They keep coming back.
So what you have to do is
have a really smart plan
that pushes to elimination,
but it has a regional approach.
And that's always
been complicated
because mosquitoes don't
follow geopolitical borders.
And so they fly
all over the place.
And we actually know how
far they can fly now.
And we're being
much more strategic
about cross-border stuff.
But to some extent, it's the
same thing with HIV and TB.
And it's actually
happened with smallpox.
If any of you care about
this, read Bill Foege's book,
"House on Fire."
It's 100 pages.
It's a really cool book.
And it's about how
smallpox ended.
And only a fraction of
it is about science.
It's actually mostly about how
you change people's mindset.
And the biggest
mindset change was
moving towards trying to
control it, to end it.
Because what you try
to do when you control
an infection like malaria
is very different than when
you try to eliminate it.
So we're really trying to
shift everyone's thinking
from it's not control.
It's not reducing the rate.
It's actually eliminating
and sticking with it
until you eliminate.
So we're very excited.
And then in the last,
literally, two years, there's
been a big shift--
and Bill Gates
has had a big role in
this-- towards shifting
our mindset to eliminating
and moving region by region.
So there's now a
plan that we think
35 to 45 countries can get
to elimination by 2020, 2025.
And then you move the next step.
And then you have to
maintain the control rates
so that you maintain
the elimination
and it doesn't bounce back.
And then you just keep pushing.
So we actually now think by
2030 we can eliminate malaria
from the planet.
I actually think,
and Bill things, we
can probably do it by
2025 if we really focus on
a little more innovation.
But then the trick's going to be
sticking with another 10 to 15
years so it doesn't come back.
You know, with all the
Zika madness around,
it's the same thing.
Or Dengue-- it's
the same mosquitoes.
So vector control, controlling
mosquito-borne diseases,
actually is more than malaria.
It actually would do the
same thing for Dengue.
It would do the same thing
for Zika, which doesn't
kill anyone, by the way.
I mean, it's really
just insanity,
the hysteria around Zika.
I actually had someone who
works in our office in Geneva,
in a global health
office, asked me
if it was safe to travel to the
United States because of Zika.
I mean, that's how
crazy it's gotten.
But it's an entry point into
how you do vector control.
There's also a new movement
to eradicate mosquitoes,
which is probably
going a little far,
and I'm not sure we can do it.
But there actually is
an elimination plan,
and elimination strategy,
and elimination mindset now.
I think we'll get there.
I actually think
we'll get there.
That's the easiest of the three.
AUDIENCE: You've used the
word "innovation" a few times
and pointed out
you don't actually
know exactly what the steps are
to eliminate these diseases.
Maybe you could
tell us a little bit
about how the Global
Fund works and maybe
with an eye towards how
that supports or attracts
innovation.
MARK DYBUL: So we're actually
a pretty unique institution.
I'll digress a little bit
because it's Friday afternoon.
I'm tired.
So 15 years ago,
if you asked anyone
what are we doing in
the world to fight AIDS,
malnutrition, better
agriculture, anything
in development, really.
The answer would have been we're
spending X amount of money.
I mean, literally,
you can go back.
That was the answer.
We're spending X. There was
no link to what are you doing
with the money, how's it going.
It really was just
how much you spend.
And there's a reason for that.
I mean, development was not
born of the most noble origins.
It was a colonial
thing to start with,
then missionary
related to colonial,
then Cold War related.
And so really the
reason the answer
was how much do you spend
is a lot of development
was making yourself feel
better, so you were giving money
to poor people because you did
some really bad things to them
historically or
making them like you.
So you're trying to
like yourself better
or you were making them like
you by giving them money.
You didn't care what they
did with it as long as they
liked you in the Cold War.
That's not why people
did development,
but that's where the money
came for development.
So there's a reason
for that answer.
Then people started to
realize, well, actually we're
giving a lot of
our tax money away.
And, you know, the Cold
War is almost over,
and we shouldn't be
doing that anymore.
And then it shifted to, what
are you doing with the money?
How are we achieving results?
How are we partnering
with people
rather than treating
them like children
and patting them on the head
by giving them some money?
And that change happened
around 2000, actually.
And then there was
something called
the Millennium Development Goals
that were born out of that.
And we, the Global
Fund, was actually
created out of that
radically new-- I mean,
really a genetic shift from
a hundred years, literally,
of thinking in development to,
how do you partner with people?
How do you bring
people together?
How do you support the countries
to achieve their objectives,
not my objective
in their country?
How do we recognize that it's
not us with all the ideas
that are coming to show
these poor people what
to do but supporting them
to be create the ideas that
will solve the problems?
So we were created that way.
So we don't have any
country presence,
unlike almost pretty much
any development organization.
We're a financial
mechanism that brings
people with the resources
together with the countries
that are implementing,
including civil society,
the private sector, all around.
And the idea was that we would
use resources to then support
countries to achieve their
objectives that they would
lead and run and innovate.
So a lot of the innovation
that we talk about-- now,
there's scientific innovation.
In India, people
were using tablets.
And literally, community
health care workers
were carrying around
backpacks filled with files.
Now they carry around a
tablet that pushes data
to a centralized source, and
they're actually improving
their efficiency dramatically.
That was pretty cool
technological advances.
There's technological
advance with drugs.
There are mosquito bed nets that
now have insecticide in them
so they kill the mosquitoes.
You don't just keep the
mosquito from biting you.
There's actually
genetic modification
of mosquitoes that can actually
have a swarm effect that
can't transmit malaria.
And they're genetically
modified so that they dominate
so that you could
actually introduce them
into a population and get
rid of the malaria-carrying
mosquitoes.
That's really cool
scientific innovation.
But then there's the
innovation on the ground.
Like, how do you keep
a person coming back
to take their antiretroviral
therapy or their TB therapy?
And those innovations
are the communities
on the ground figuring it out.
How to keep girls
in school, those
are the communities
on the ground.
We've actually gone in and
looked at some of this.
And it's amazing
what they come up
with and the solutions
that they find.
So we were designed,
basically, to provide
the resources to
stimulate that innovation
from a national level down
to the individual health care
worker.
Hasn't always worked
the way we wanted it to.
We're trying to do
more and more of it.
We have actually created
an innovation hub
to bring the best ideas
together, to stimulate them,
to catalyze the change,
to be a little more
proactive in bringing the
lessons learned around
as we learn them.
But also to be
comfortable with--
and this is something health
people, medical people,
have always had difficulty, be
comfortable with not knowing.
Be comfortable with
playing a little bit.
Be comfortable
familiar with failure,
to let this innovation bloom.
And that's what we're getting
more and more and better
and better at.
It's really cool the
shift in how we've
thought about development.
The mindset hasn't changed.
I still hear people talk
about, oh, those poor Africans.
We're coming to help.
They're actually
doing all the work.
We're just providing
them with support.
And it's really remarkable.
I've had the privilege to go
to the same communities 15
years apart and to
see the difference
from the hopelessness,
the total despair
to these incredibly bright
people who have come up
with the best solutions that
are solving their own problems--
to empower them, including
with the technological tools
like a tablet, but
to empower them
to then solve their problems.
And that's what the Global
Fund was created to do.
So we collect money, and
then we disperse money.
We disperse about
$4 billion a year,
collect and disperse about $4
billion a year, which makes us
the largest multilateral
funder of the global health
of any kind for HIV,
TB, and malaria.
The US government has
a bigger HIV program.
We have a bigger malaria
program and a bigger TB program.
This is pretty
exciting, actually.
The countries now are
spending as much or more
of their own money to
combat HIV, TB, and malaria
as coming from the outside.
There's still this
perception all the money
is coming from outside.
They're actually paying 50%
of their HIV, about 52%,
48% of their malaria,
and about 80% of TB.
Because 70% of the
TB in the world
is in the BRICS countries.
So they're the ones
mostly paying for it.
So what we do in those
environments is actually
try to catalyze
change, innovation,
bring innovation,
share innovation,
but not in the sense
of I have an answer.
You have to take it.
More in the sense of, how
do we solve a problem?
And that's what the
fund was created to do.
So it's actually
a pretty neat job.
We're a Swiss
foundation, but we're
a multilateral organization
that functions like the UN,
but we're not the UN.
You're back.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Christian.
Hi again.
So I wonder a little
bit about tuberculosis,
like more technical.
As I understand, like
tuberculosis, your researchers
don't really know how it works?
And is there a treatment?
Like, if I get it
tomorrow, is there
a medicine to take for me?
And how expensive is it to
actually technically take
a pill and be good?
MARK DYBUL: So the fact
that you don't know
is actually pretty cool because
it means-- which is true.
Most people don't have to
worry about tuberculosis.
So they only tuberculosis
in Switzerland or the United
States, or actually almost
all of Western Europe,
is TB-- same for malaria--
that gets imported.
Someone goes someplace.
They get coughed on.
They get TB.
Or they go someplace and
get bit by a mosquito,
and they come back.
That's the only case.
It's imported, which means
you can eliminate it, right?
Because it's been eliminated
in a lot of places.
So TB is in some ways the
most frustrating to me
because we have
curative therapy.
It takes six months to cure
tuberculosis, six months.
HIV is life-long therapy.
could you imagine if
we had curative therapy
in six months for HIV?
I mean, we have the activism.
We have the galvanism.
HIV would be gone.
The rate of decline of
TB, despite the fact
that we have a six
month curative therapy,
is 1.5% per year.
It's pathetic.
You know, by that rate, it
will take 200 years to end TB.
And what's even worse
is while we have a 1.5%
decline in new infections
per year-- wow-- because
of the growth in the
population, we actually
have more people with TB even
though the rate is slightly
going down.
So it's enormously frustrating.
One of the biggest problems
is no one cares about it
because it's mostly poor
people in inner cities
that governments don't
spend a lot of time on.
There are people who
don't understand that they
have access to health care.
And they literally will be
coughing themselves to death
before they go to a hospital
or before they go to a clinic.
And by the time they've
done that, they've infected
a whole bunch of other people.
And then the programs
aren't particularly good.
And what's equally
problematic right now
is the public sector-- so India
has 25% of the TB in the world.
You put India and China
together, you're almost 45%.
Again, the BRICS are 70%.
Development agencies
aren't going
to be doing a lot of
stuff in BRICS countries.
And in southern Africa,
it's largely linked to HIV,
as I mentioned.
And interestingly, a lot of it
is related to migratory miners.
It's not their fault. They
do one mine in Mozambique.
That season ends.
And then they go to their home
family in another country.
And they were on their
TB drugs in the mines,
because they actually
test you because you're
in a confined area.
It's not good to have
TB people in your mines.
But when they leave,
they stop their drugs.
And then they go home and cough.
And they cough on their family.
And then everyone in the
community-- and the data
tell us this-- get infected.
And then they go to a new
mine, and they start a new drug
regimen, which is
different than the one
they took before because
the countries aren't aligned
in the regimens that you take.
And then they go
to a new family--
because often they have more
than one family because they're
migratory workers--
in another country,
start the process again.
And it keeps going and going.
So about a third of all
new TB in southern Africa
is from migratory
miners, a third of it.
And because it crosses borders,
we've not followed it at all.
We're just starting to do that.
So this is not a
technical problem.
This is actually just a public
health approach problem.
And it's a willingness to
reach people who are migrating,
people who are poor
in inner cities.
This is not a technical problem.
This is a social problem.
The only technical
problem is diagnosis,
which isn't particularly easy.
Hopefully we'll have
a new urine test.
And increasingly, we
think of TB in the lungs.
TB actually can be anywhere.
TB actually used to be known
as the inscrutable disease.
Anything could be TB.
And there's more and more
TB that's not in the lungs,
and that's even
harder to diagnose.
So the diagnosis
part is actually
the technically difficult thing.
But once you've diagnosed
and identified someone,
if you take your
drugs every day,
you're cured in six months.
AUDIENCE: Why do they
stop taking the drug?
Is it the educational problem,
that they don't know that--?
MARK DYBUL: When's the last time
you took, say, an antibiotic?
When's the last time you took a
drug that required you to take
it for 10 days, 15 days.
AUDIENCE: That was a
while ago, but I did it.
MARK DYBUL: Did you?
Yeah.
So one of my
favorite studies-- I
used to be an infectious
disease doctor
before I became a bureaucrat.
And one of my favorite studies
was among infectious disease
doctors who were given a
14-day course of antibiotics
because they had an infection.
About 30% finished it.
These are infectious
disease doctors, right?
So the natural
course for anything
is, and I bet most of you have
done this, you start taking it.
As soon as you feel
better, you stop taking it.
And taking drugs every
day for six months
isn't particularly fun,
and it's not even easy.
And six months is a
relatively long time.
So we started something called
Directly Observed Therapy,
which actually works, but it got
misused because public health
bureaucrats got a hold of it.
And we created a bureaucracy
rather than listening to people
and understanding how to do it.
And then think about HIV,
which is lifelong therapy.
And the other thing about
especially HIV drugs
is every time you take
a pill it reminds you
that you have something.
Most people don't
want to be reminded
that they have an infection.
They'd rather think
they're healthy.
So it's normal--
was it you who said
we should get psychologists?
It's normal human behavior.
And if infectious disease
doctors can't even
finish a 14-day
course of antibiotics,
just imagine how
complicated this is?
AUDIENCE: Can't we do
something like [INAUDIBLE]
that you operate in?
I mean, there are
like preventive--
MARK DYBUL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So yeah--
MARK DYBUL: Yeah, no, no, no.
We're getting more
and more to that.
So we don't have them
yet for tuberculosis.
But people are worried--
and part of the problem
is there is no market
for tuberculosis drugs.
Tuberculosis is for poor
people in poor countries.
So why would a company invest
in an innovative tuberculosis
product that they're never
going to make any money on?
HIV is different
because there are
enough people in Western markets
that they can make money on.
Malaria is the same thing.
AUDIENCE: But you have money.
MARK DYBUL: No, we
don't do research.
The Gates Foundation and
the US National Institute
and other national
institutions have actually
created partnerships.
What we can do is say
they'll be a market.
So if you produce
that, we'll buy it.
You will make a huge
profit, but really,
if you're a drug company
executive and you can make
Viagra or you can make an
anti-tuberculosis drug,
which one do you
think your board is
going to want you to make?
So you have to actually
stimulate these low profit
margin investments.
And we've gotten
much better at that.
And we do have a role
as a bulk procurer,
but there's not a
lot of incentive.
But there is really cool stuff.
So there are now two
injectable HIV products
that last, we hope, three months
that are being put together.
We're not sure if they'll
work for treatment,
but they'll work for
prevention for sure.
For those of you who
don't know, there's
also something called
depo provera, which
is an injectable family planning
product that we're working
to put in with the HIV drugs.
So imagine, we could actually
have a drug-- one injection
every three months that prevents
HIV and is a family planning
tool.
There actually is a
long-lasting subcutaneous family
planning device too.
The problem is volume.
There's the biochemistry.
It's the volume, and
it's the reaction,
but we're getting there.
But there hasn't
been the incentive.
It's not actually the science.
We could probably figure out.
It's the incentive.
And this is where the Gates
Foundation and a lot of others
are investing to create
those technologies.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I'm interested in how
the problems you're addressing
are related to poverty.
You mentioned several
times how that's entwined,
I guess, in different ways.
How closely linked
do you see that is?
And do you do work with
anti-poverty organizations
as part of what you're doing?
MARK DYBUL: It's
a great question,
and it really gets to-- TB
is a disease of poverty.
Malaria is in a lot
of ways a disease
of poverty because it
relates to sanitation,
and water, and access,
having a living condition.
But we can't do everything, and
the expertise that's required
is completely different.
And so we don't actually
invest in anti-poverty efforts.
We work with organizations that
do like the World Bank, the UN
Development Project, and
others, and fundamentally
with the countries,
because economic growth,
as long as it's equitable,
actually can be great in terms
of lifting out of these things.
HIV, as you probably well
know, is not a disease
of the poorest of the poor.
It's actually a disease of
the slightly more mobile,
including in Africa, and
those vulnerable populations.
So we link with them.
This has been one
of the myths that's
been annoying a lot
of people is, well,
just have economic growth, and
that'll solve all our disease
problems.
Well, that's only
true if you equitably
distribute the resources.
And we're becoming a more
and more unequal world.
We're actually involved in
something called the Equitable
Access Initiative, which
I'm not going to get into,
which is pretty
cool, which is trying
to address some of these
issues through a health lens.
But it's a really
good point, and it
gets to how can you
stay within your mandate
and still have an impact?
So we try to link with and
then support countries to have
the fiscal space so
that they can actually
combat these infections
at the same time
that their economies
are growing.
AUDIENCE: So I'm about to
raise a subject that is bound
to be a little bit contagious.
But one of the
measures that's been
taken against mosquito-borne
diseases such as malaria
are insecticides.
Now, DDT is, of course,
far from a good substance,
and it was banned in I think
the late '80s, around the time.
And the developmental
age was also
made dependent on
banning the use of DDT.
Now, of course,
I'm not a chemist.
I'm not aware of exactly
how justified [INAUDIBLE]
was, but by some
accounts, actually
banning this substance has
cost up to a couple of million
or tens of millions
of innocent lives.
Now, so I've got two
questions for you.
How justified was this scare?
And is there research into other
insecticides that may actually
be just as effective as DDT
but less damaging to our lives?
MARK DYBUL: Yes.
And this is still,
unfortunately, a debate,
but it has changed
a lot since then.
So WHO has certified
DDT as safe.
We buy a lot of DDT, and
countries use a lot of DDT.
Some countries still
don't because they still
remember these things, but DDT
is now a valid insecticide,
and we support countries
to buy a lot of it.
There are side effects.
There's side effects
to everything.
But used smartly
and the side effects
that we used to see we
don't see so much anymore.
There are second and third
generation insecticides that
are as if not more effective.
The problem with all of them
is resistance over time,
and we're already
starting to see--
so there's DDT resistance.
And we use this other one.
But interestingly,
then the mosquitoes
that were resistant to
DDT die because they
got sprayed with the new one,
and then DDT sensitive again.
So we actually have to
measure periodically
and you rotate insecticides.
And then there's
a new generation
because we're actually
starting to see resistance
to all of the insecticides.
And we also then put
insecticides in the bed nets
so it's not just the spray.
Because it's pretty cool.
You kill the mosquito.
You don't just prevent
it from biting you.
And that has an impact.
So what we saw early on is
with insecticide treated nets,
if you put nets in a village,
the next village actually
had a reduction in
its malaria rate
because the
mosquitoes were dying.
But because we use
the same insecticide,
we then started amplifying
the insecticide resistance
with the bed nets
and the sprays.
So we do cycle now.
The third generation is great,
but it's very expensive.
It's about three times as
expensive as the other two.
And so we're playing
both to reduce the cost
but also in how we rotate
in an intelligent way, which
gets back to elimination.
You actually do need
spraying for elimination.
There is no silver
bullet for anything.
So you have to treat.
You have to spray.
You have these bed nets.
You have to put it
all together, and you
have to do it in a
public health approach.
But for the most part,
we're past the DDT issue.
There are still some
countries and still
some people who
periodically [INAUDIBLE].
But it's certified by WHO,
and most countries now
are comfortable using it.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Daniel.
I'm an attorney with some
interest in public health
law and ethics.
You mentioned the interests
of pharmaceutical companies
before.
I just want to ask how
intellectual property
rights, especially patent laws,
factor into that whole debate.
I know I haven't
followed that entirely,
but there's something
like a Doha declaration
that enables the poorer
countries, the WTO member
states, to issue
compulsory licenses.
But that doesn't work
in all instances,
especially not if
those countries don't
have the facilities to actually
manufacture these drugs.
Can you go a little
bit into that?
MARK DYBUL: So it's a
really important area,
and actually the availability
of generic products
is one of the factors in
the remarkable reduction
on the price of all
of the products.
So antiretrovirals when we
were putting together PEPFAR,
were about $1,500 to
$2,500 per year per person.
We're now down to $80, which
is pretty breathtaking.
And generic competition
and manufacture actually
had a lot to do with that.
For us, intellectual property,
and for where we invest,
has not yet been a huge issue.
Because the vast
majority of the countries
we work in don't have
intellectual property laws.
And because most of
the companies now,
and it took a lot
of advocacy and took
a lot of public beating
up to get them there,
but most of the companies now
don't enforce their patents
even where they exist in low
and low-middle income countries.
The tricky part is
upper-middle income countries.
And that's where complications
are starting to arise.
We don't actually
support countries
to buy a lot of-- by the time
we're in upper-middle income
countries, we're mostly
investing in civil society
strengthening, key
affected populations,
human rights-focused efforts,
rather than large procurements
because the countries do those.
But there are other groups
that work on this issue.
And there is a new
UN commission on it.
It's tough.
I mean, there was a study
published a couple months ago
that showed that countries
that issued compulsory licenses
actually paid more for products
than countries that didn't
issue compulsory licenses.
But the threat of the
compulsory license
probably led to the companies
reducing their prices
to a level that
allowed for that.
So it's a complex environment.
We are not overly
engaged in that
because we're not a
trade organization.
We're not a technical
organization.
There are organizations that
do, and we partner with them.
Unitade is one.
Medicines Patent Pool,
which is actually
a cool mechanism whereby
countries give away--
most companies now, most of them
just give away their licenses
to a generic manufacturer
because they're not
going make any money
of it off anyway.
It is a problem for
TB and malaria drugs.
And we're a little more
engaged, but we mostly partner
with the groups that are
heavily engaged in that.
UNAIDS is very involved, UNDP.
There is potentially
another round of Doha.
It's been blocked for a while.
There are free trade
agreements, which some people
think are going backwards.
But I'm not competent
to talk about those.
There is a body of literature.
Medicine [INAUDIBLE]
is very involved.
Oxfam's very involved.
So there is a body of literature
if you'd like to look at it.
We're less directly engaged
because we're really
a financing mechanism,
not a technical agency.
We partner with
the groups that do.
There are really issues,
but they're complicated.
And like everything,
dogma and simple answers
probably isn't it.
There's something in between.
I was talking to the CEO of
a big pharmaceutical company
about intellectual property--
and unfortunately very few CEOs
feel this way these
days, there was a time--
he was like, look, intellectual
property doesn't give you
the right to charge
whatever you want to charge.
And it's the area
under the curve.
If you sell 100 things for
$1 or one thing for $100,
you make the same
amount of money.
So there's an in-between
between access and pricing,
which unfortunately, because
of shareholders and a lot
of other stuff, some of the
pharmaceutical companies today
remind me of the
railroad companies
or the electrical companies
that are just outrageous what's
happening.
But at the same time,
you need some incentive
to continue to invest in,
say, producing a new TB
drug or a new malaria drug.
And if there's no
protection of any kind--
we've actually created something
as an innovation which we hope
is kind of an in-between
that could solve the problem.
The reason for
intellectual property
is to have a market,
just basically
have a long-term market
to recover costs,
which get grossly inflated.
And we know they do.
So we had this great idea.
You know, pooled procurement
works really well.
It brings prices down, a great
way to bring prices down.
We now have innovators
out bidding generics
because they know
what their volume is.
So as long as you can
guarantee a volume,
you can actually
reduce your price.
If you can't guarantee
a volume, then you're
kind of spot pricing.
So we had the insight that if
we pooled procurement and made
it available, which
we'd been doing,
but we'd been managing it, we
could really reduce prices.
So in the last two years, we
reduced the price of bed nets
for malaria by
40%, in two years,
by just pooling the
procurement and negotiating.
But that's us doing it.
What happens to a country
when we're not there
to do it for them anymore?
So we challenged
our procurement team
to come up with a solution,
and they came back
with a simple brilliant thing
which probably half of you
in the room thought of.
So we basically created a
Kayak.com, Priceline.com
for health commodities.
It's called Wambo.org.
We just launched it, actually.
And we believe this will
be the pathway, eventually,
to have open competition
for medical products,
not just the ones we deal.
We actually want to spin it
off to a global public health
good so that all
health commodities can
be on it as a global public
health good with no skimming
of money so that you will have
predictable markets, long term
markets, which would then allow
for pricing that might overcome
some of these issues.
The other piece of it
is it also promotes
innovation of companies.
If you talk to companies
in Africa or China
for that matter, no one will
invest in quality assurance
and getting quality products or
even in the product themselves,
because there's no market.
The question every
investor has is how are you
going to out compete
country by country,
open up a market in 75
countries, on your own?
There's no access.
This will give automatic access.
All you have to do is
have a quality product.
And it will go on there, and you
can price it wherever you want.
And you can drive
the price changes.
So we think this will stimulate
innovation and commodities.
We think it will stimulate
a price reduction,
and it's a simple
technological solution.
It's also a way that if
you have a long enough term
predictability, the smart
companies will start pricing
in a much different way.
And then intellectual
property, which
was your protective
mechanism, might
be a little less necessary.
AUDIENCE: What's that
name of the [INAUDIBLE]?
MARK DYBUL: It's called
Wambo.org, W-A-M-B-O dot O-R-G.
You would understand why.
I was like, why the
hell would we pick
a name that no one understands?
Did you know what Yahoo meant?
Did you know what Google meant?
No.
So you create a word
that means nothing really
and turn it into something
that has a meaning on its own.
So it's in its early stages.
We actually just launched it.
It was a massive effort.
For now, it's just
available to some
of what we call principle
implementers, the people
we fund.
By the end of the
year, we're going
to let any country
that wants to use it
for HIV, TB, and malaria.
And then our goal is
within the next year
to work with other global
health organizations
to create a governance mechanism
to turn it into a global health
good.
You could see the VA
and the National Health
Services starting to use this.
We'll get into a lot
of trouble, actually,
when it gets to that
point, but it will be fun.
I think we're at
your 6:00-- it's
your bird saying it's
time for happy hour.
MALE SPEAKER: I think that
cue to finish has come.
This is our Heidi song, and it
means that TGIF is starting.
So for the two of
you in the room
that don't know what that
means, please have a beer.
Thank you very much, Mark.
It's been great
listening to you.
[APPLAUSE]